Vibrio cholera is a pathogenic bacterium
that causes a terrible disease that's
called cholera
so it's named after the bacterium it's
estimated that there are hundreds of
thousands of cases of Cholera a year and
people get cholera from eating or
drinking contaminated food or water and
so cholera can get into the water supply
and when people ingest cholera and it
gets into their bodies it causes a
disease that that causes this massive
diarrhea that people get and they can
actually die from cholera from
dehydration during this acute phase and
so cholera is prevalent in the world
it's prevalent in places that don't have
always have access to clean water
so typically poorer countries or
countries that are undergoing civil
strife or Wars or catastrophes like
earthquakes where the water supply gets
interrupted and it's this very insidious
bacterium because its strategy is not to
stay in the host the human host forever
so it gets in when people drink
contaminated water it multiplies like
crazy it releases all of these toxins
they give you the illness the symptoms
the diarrhea right and then it's
multiplying in the people's gut and it
gets out by the gazillions out into the
environment and then the strategy is
then to go and set the next person so it
sort of comes in guns loaded it's very
infectious and it gets out at very high
numbers to do it again and it causes a
terrible debilitating disease that
disease would be gone if people had
access to clean water but they don't and
so it is endemic in different parts of
the world so the disease cholera would
disappear if the world always or almost
always had access to clean water but
they don't and so clean water is a
trillion dollar problem and it's a
political problem it's not about not
knowing how to do it right many
countries don't have cholera because we
have clean water and so the real fantasy
is that everyone would have access to
clean water
then we wouldn't need new medicines for
cholera but in fact much of the world
doesn't have that as a luxury or a
necessity and so that's why we have to
make medicines for cholera because their
sad depressing truth is that the people
who suffer from cholera won't have
access to clean water in the near future
and so we have to do something else
even though the real best strategy is to
give clean water but that's not on the
horizon and that's truth there's a
number of problems with cholera which is
the current medicines don't get to the
people that's a real problem the second
one is the caller is resistant to many
of the currently used antibiotics and
the third is that they just don't work
particularly well against that bacterium
and so it would be really great news if
a scientist or scientist could discover
a vaccine for cholera that was effective
or a very potent medicine that is really
cheap so it could be given to lots of
people who don't have the ability to pay
for it
you